hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
unserem letzten kari antwortet für
dieses jahr
der start war der shorthander und ein
englisch sollte teveren of you and
channel das video von the extent that
matter of time and who work hier in
action is jo ok jetzt reden wir wieder
auf deutsch wie beantworten heute zum
letzten mal eure fragen und wir möchten
anfangen mit einem ganz ganz großen
dankeschön von unserem herzen
wir haben vor zwei wochen unsere passion
kampagne gestartet und unsere easy
german übungen ja veröffentlicht und
angekündigt und seitdem haben schon hier
haben wir jetzt insgesamt 278 patch 1.1
russischen nein so viele klassen und wir
freuen uns wahnsinnig und das ist sogar
so ja ich kann euch gar nicht sagen wie
sehr uns das freut das ist jedes mal
wenn mein handy klingelt ich hab sogar
einen speziellen vibrationsalarm für
diese e-mails ihr einkommen und das sind
immer so am anfang waren es sehr viele
und jetzt sind es so 345 am tag und
jedes mal wenn sie mit ihrem account ist
das so viel und so gedrückt von euch so
ein virtueller drucker ist das sozusagen
als wenn ihr uns so so umarmen bildet
und danke sagen würdet und dafür möchten
wir euch danke sagen danke dass ihr uns
unterstützt und vertraut wir haben so
viele neue pläne für das nächste jahr
und dass ihr uns dabei unterstützt gibt
uns richtig viel kraft und auch mut und
auch viel mehr spaß an der arbeit
weil wir wissen dass wir im nächsten
jahr mit eure unterstützung ja sehr viel
mehr machen können
und auch neue wege gehen können wir
möchten im nächsten jahr viele von euch
treffen hier in berlin aber euch auch
besuchen in euren schulen
wir fahren zum beispiel im januar nach
polen in jammers heimatland und werden
dort schulen besuchen die deutsch lernen
und wir möchten auch noch mal eine
andere länder fahren und euch dort
besuchen und werden aber auch andere
sachen machen wir möchten zum beispiel
neues equipment kaufen für unsere kamera
und langfristig würden wir gerne unser
team erweitern und auch noch ein oder
zwei leute in unserem team anstellen
damit vier ja besser produzieren können
denn im moment es ist immer noch so dass
wir so es ist immer
last minute alles auf die letzte minute
und es ist auch viel stress manchmal
wenn wir nur zu zweit sind wenn einer
von uns krank ist dann ist das schon ein
problem wie wir die easyjet folge in
dieser woche fertig bekommen aber wir
bemühen uns trotzdem immer und wir sind
total stolz dass für das jede woche
geschafft haben sollte nämlich zwei
jahren
okay sind wir wollen willst du dich
liebe freut sich richtig jahres wollen
wir zuletzt so wie gar nicht frei ist
und ich will mir dass ich gleich die
erste frage für euch vorlese und die
lautet nein nein ich freue mich total
das ist gar nicht gar nicht so einfach
zu erzählen aber wir haben das gefühl
ihr nimmt uns ernst und das projekt
ernst und in dem ihr unseres projekt
unterstützt verleiht ihr auch dem
gleichen projekt mehr völlig andere
seriosität im grunde und wichtigkeit und
sie haben ja ganz klein angefangen und
mittlerweile haben wir das gefühl wir
sind nicht alleine sondern mit eurer
unterstützung können wir das projekt
noch unglaublich hoch burschen und
unglaublich mehr interessanter und mir
nützlicher machen als es sogar jetzt
schon ist und und das macht uns ja sehr
sehr glücklich und momentan auch
euphorisch aber das ist alles dank euch
dankeschön jetzt haben wir die erste
frage endlich okay also die frage lautet
don't von leonardo da vinci
dementsprechend die frage karim in space
in language nicht die erste frage
danke leo leonardo doodle für diesen
hinweis weißt du was döbel auf deutsch
heißt wenig als duncan leonardo dollar
für den hinweis des jahres bei easy
german jetzt wirklich nur interessiert
welche sprache ist das weil das ist da
das ist ja auch da freue ich mich drauf
und weiter geht's ja nun aber das ist
die erste von ihnen kommt diese das
nicht die nächste frage kommt von ist
abgeschnitten acht wochen alles klar
die nächste frage von mohamed al fayed
hallo sind alle deutscher stubenhocker
oder ist das nicht war das ist wahr
machen wir dass es sehr war kommt man
heute zb scheint die sonne draußen was
machen wir wir machen ein video in
unserer küche
warum nicht zum beispiel und ich bin
zwar kein deutscher aber trotzdem ein
gutes beispiel für ein oberstimm hocker
ich lebe jetzt seit anderthalb jahren
oder zwei jahren in berlin und ich habe
herzlich wenig von berlin gesehen weil
ich hoffe immer in meiner studie an
seinem computer hier vorne ist es steht
er nun spielt er gitarre oder schneidet
ihr sie den videos das macht ja nicht
meisten wechsel frage ganz aber
allgemein mir ist das auch schon
aufgefallen ich glaube das ist aber ein
bisschen eine andere kultur und das hat
auch ein wenig mit dem wetter zu tun
ihr seht dass das in ländern wo es sehr
warm ist spielt sich sehr viel mehr
leben auf der straße er dem in namibia
zum beispiel ist das zuhause eigentlich
nur zum über nacht
richtig und dementsprechend legen die
leute auch weniger wert auf die wohnung
oder so weil es nicht so wichtig ist man
verbringt nicht so viel zeit und viel
mehr wert legt man auf die sachen die
draußen stattfinden und auf die sachen
die man draußen dabei hat oder
vielleicht auch auf ein auto zum
beispiel mit dem man halt sich
fortbewegt familie ein smartphone
viel wichtiger als in deutschland zum
beispiel wieandt in deutschland in
unseren wohnungen noch unser laptops
oder unser business dass du dich nicht
so fall gemeint aber es ist schon so
wenn man sich diese länder herkunft kann
zum beispiel auch dass er jetzt so weit
hergeholte theorie aber ikea kommt ja
auch aus schweden
da ist es eher kalt und dann
beschäftigen sich die leute mehr damit
dass sie drin machen und wie es darin
aussieht ja solange sie nicht in der
sauna stecken
okay das jetzt einfach nur mal karrees
private verschwörungstheorie okay
nächste frage und zwar kommt von george
batten ich liebe isermann team vor allem
janusz er sehr menschlich und mit ist
mir schon aufgefallen
naja dich immer ihr heimisches ganz lieb
und ganz nett das hätte ich ihnen ja
nicht geheiratet
ja danke george für diesen netten
kommentar
gegen den habe ich nur für dich raus
gesucht haben gesehen ist warum übrigens
dieser woche auch sehr viele kommentare
zu klaus bekommen so klaus wird
demnächst wieder erscheinen weil dann
der nächste kandidat reichsmark an
ich habe eine frage an euch wie geht wie
gehen die deutschen damit um die nazi
vergangenheit besonders mit polnisch
leute war die geschichte noch schlechter
ist ihr seid eine deutsche frau ist das
üblich ja früher wurde man das dafür
aufgegangen
nz nz
denn es sei meine beste deutsche
freundin ist auch halb
deutsch halb polnisch und jannik mich an
ihr vater dankeschön kessel vielleicht
liebe grüße aus indien bereits quasi auf
das üblich ist dass es deutsche und
polnische paarung
es gibt sogar sehr viele sehr sehr viele
deutsch-polnische paare und ich glaube
auch dass polen die größte nationalität
aus sind die in deutschland als die
größte gruppe nicht deutsche die in
deutschland wohnen ja obwohl sie nicht
sichtbar sind weil sie sehr schnell
verschwinden und sich anpassen nicht
auffallen sie tragen keine turbane sie
sehen genauso hässlich aus wie die
deutschen
das ist ja toll aber es ist schon es
gibt schon große polnische community in
deutschland die auch sehr wohl nicht nur
einfach ihrer kultur vergessen sondern
auch ihre kultur leben und es ist
durchaus üblich und deutschland und
polen haben wir eine sehr sehr lange
geschichte zusammen die nicht nur die
ns-zeit umfasst und auch nicht in der ns
zeit beginnt sondern ja es gibt sehr
viel schon mit den kämpfen im
mittelalter richtig wir haben uns schon
im mittelalter geklappt aber gab es zum
beispiel kommt aus einer familie die
ursprünglich die polnisch war etwas
gesehen aber in deutsch in deutsch im
deutschen teil sich mal genau meine
familie lebt in ostpreußen und war
ethnisch verschieden und das ist heute
komischerweise ziemlich schwer
nachvollziehbar also eine familie und
erleben endlich alle möglichen leute in
ostpreußen und damals war das gang und
gäbe damals war dass die normalität und
erst die ns-zeit die nazi-zeit hat das
ganze polarisiert und plötzlich ist man
entweder pole gewesen oder deutscher und
wenn einem eine deutsche frau die einen
polen heiraten sollte
konnte auch aufgehangen werden oder
umgekehrt
aber diese dieser idiotische
polarisierung kam erst in der nazizeit
und die gehört auch schnell vergessen
weil tatsächlich ist die polnisch
deutsche geschichte eine sehr lange
geschichte und eine sehr ineinander
gehende geschichte also es gab immer
große gebiete die umstritten waren wo
fast genau so viele deutsche wie polen
gelebt haben und die deutschen waren
militärisch meistens stärker deshalb
haben sie sich dann unterwegs schuldig
gemacht
estlands daher ist das lands clown und
alles mögliche aber wenn du wenn man das
auf der zum beispiel handwerker ebene
sieht ja dann gibt es eine totale
zusammenarbeit es gibt in polnischer
sprache sehr viele gerade in handwerker
sprache sehr viele wörter die
offensichtlich aus dem deutschen
entlehnt würden also deutschen polen
ja genau es wird zum ist richtig ist
kann nur besser werden
das hast du noch eine frei für uns oder
willst uns noch einen vortrag ich
wünsche euch einen vortrag leben halten
aber über eine ganz andere land waren
die zuschauer
ok ich muss nur sagen als pole in
deutschland fühle ich mich sauwohl es
ist wirklich angenehm und gerade in
berlin fühlt man sich noch willkommener
nicht wegen den berliner die uns
wahrscheinlich hassen aber wegen der
internationalen
gemeint gemeinschaften stimmung hier
also ja richtig mir gehts berlin ist
sowieso international zeigt uns doch
noch eine frage an
okay wir kommen übrigens im januar nach
polen
der januar anfang februar sind in zwei
wochen in polen wo familie mit nachwuchs
mir dein geld nie astrophysik topolsky
und dann fahren die witze vielleicht
auch noch trotzen und katowice und krank
hof wenn ihr dort wohnt schreibt uns mal
kinder
ok ich meine nächste frage kommt vom
summer rain warum gibt es keine leute
aus russland er meint unsere letzte kari
antwortet die wir auf der weihnachts
party gemacht haben weil sich da
zufällig keiner war kein anderer grund
wenn ihr aus russland kommt in berlin
seit schreibt uns besucht uns bei der
nächsten esi beim nächsten easyjet
stammtisch der findet übrigens am jetzt
muss ich schnell nach unten am 13 januar
oder ist ein anruf ich lehne ihn ab
wenn wir drehen gerade in dem wir können
ein durchschnitt stimmt schon abgelehnt
übrigens wir arbeiten mit mussten total
viel zusammen die haben eine riesige
easy raschen
[Musik]
wir haben etliche easy german mit
russischen
moderatorin gemacht zumindest einen
danke ja mit dreizehnter januar ist
unser nächster easy german stammtisch in
berlin und den link findet ihr bei
facebook guck mal rein facebook.com
eko-punkt com / german videos dort
findet ihr unseren stammtisch jetzt
gehts weiter
wir müssen uns kurz fassen ok am dreht
sagt ismail schreibt ich habe eine warum
lässt du deutsch hoffentlich dass du
antwortest bald beantworten wir doch
ganz schnell
die katze ist die atari amische warum
unterrichten wir deutsch priwall kurz
halt ich bitte korea genau weil wenn du
deutsch sprichst hast du gute chancen in
der welt sich vorteile zu erarbeiten
soll
das ist also deine persönliche
motivation es war nicht persönlich das
war die antwort von dem alten mann von
unserer erpii solche vorteile hast du
dir erarbeitete welt ja das war sehr
überraschend weil am anfang habe ich
deutsch überhaupt nicht gemocht weil ich
war so ein typischer pole der der
deutsch aus den kriegsfilm könnte und
deutsch alleine den klang gehasst hat
und sein 14 polnische schweine wenn der
hoch und dann aber soll mit der zeit
sich richtig in diese sprache verliebt
hat und und ich bin jedes mal glücklich
wenn ich deutsch lese gerade sachen aus
philosophie ja auch aber philosophie
ehrlich gesagt ließ sich und höre mir an
ehe endlich ein deutsches einfach süß
ich und ich verstehe ich spreche deutsch
schon
dann schickt aber ich verstehe deutsch
hundertprozentig und es ist immer so
angenehm sich irgendwelche reportagen
uns hören ich mag einfach wie deutsch
klingt und ich mag die geschwindigkeit
von deutsch und ich mag die die art wie
sie sachen beschreiben ich liebe deutsch
ja und die haben schon selber deutsch
gelernt deswegen hatte er eigentlich die
diese und video zu drehen und ich mache
das einfach nur weil es so viele leute
gibt die sich darüber freuen und das
freut uns genommen es ist ja schön wenn
man einen job hat über den sich viele
leute freunde manche leute die mir ganz
nach ins büro dann gehen sie angst
wieder nach hause und wissen gar nicht
warum sie das machen und diesen job mag
ich einfach deshalb ich hab das ja nicht
studiert oder so ich mag das weil ich
mich über eure kommentare freuen wenn
wir die typische youtube letschin werdet
bei uns das freuen uns richtig von
herzen und deswegen machen wir dieses
projekt jahren schauen wir noch eine
frage jetzt langsam zum ende kommen
haben alle schon abgeschaltet
ok dann zuletzt möchte ich euch etwas
erzählen da war jetzt keiner mehr
zuguckt und zwar ein werkzeug um deutsch
zu lernen
gerade für etwas fortgeschrittenen leute
also leute die fähig sind dieses
programm zu gucken ist natürlich das
lesen ihr liest bücher eins nach dem
anderen am besten zwei bücher in der
woche und dann macht ihr ungeheuren
fortschritt ja allerdings
am einfachsten geht es mit einer kinder
applikation die er auf einem smartphone
habt und der vorteil hier ist dass ich
bin ein ausgesprochener kurze so hier
habt ihr einen deutschen text ja und
wenn ich jetzt ein wort nicht verstehen
zum beispiel fatah dann würde ich dieses
wort einfach an einfach berühren
und zack da oben kommt eine definition
vater peter ursprünglich leitwort der
kinder sprachen übersetzen
du kommst auch ein übersetzung nicht
aber man kann sich das selber auswählen
definition weil du musst du musst eine
ein wörterbuch laden und da gibt es ganz
verschiedene wörterbücher und mein
deutsches jetzt schon gut genug dass ich
ein deutsch deutsches wörterbuch habe
man bzw
ein mann der ein oder mehrere kinder
gezeugt hat ich empfehle das euch ich
wundere mich weil ich habe noch
eigentlich keinen getroffen der mir
gesagt hat er ja ich habe das auf meinem
smartphone und lesebücher dieses jahr
zum beispiel wollte sie nicht bücher
lesen was du siehst mich ja nächstes
jahr werden wir noch ein paar weitere
sachen raus bringen und wenn ihr übungen
gucken wollte wenn ihr übung machen
wollte unseren episoden und werdet
wieder ein patch 1
hiernach und dort bekommt das video von
uns bekommt ihr dort eine übung ein
übungsplatz mit vokabeln und grammatik
übung und mit texten auch also das ist
eine perfekte ich als seele der deutsch
gelernt hat danke auf jeden fall es ist
eine sinnvolle verbindung ist dieses
video sich einfach aus spaß
hoffentlich anzugucken aber dann sich
die texte einmal durchlesen und ehe
profitiert zehnfach davon
danke dass ihr uns unterstützt haben
danke an alle von euch die easy german
möglich gemacht haben dieses jahr und
nächstes jahr erst recht mit eurer
unterstützung werden wir noch sehr weit
kommen da sind davon überzeugt und wir
möchten euch ja von unserem herzen von
jannis und von meinem herzen ganz doll
danke sagen und wir sehen uns im
nächsten jahr wieder schaut rein am
montag oder dienstag auf diesem kanal
werdet ihr die neue folge finden
seid gespannt werden sie wird morgen an
silvester gedreht aber sie ist nicht wie
die folge vom letzten jahr ja warum
dass dies auf die leute ja gute
geschichte vor neun jahren genau feiert
kommt gut ins neue jahr und wir freuen
uns auf euch nächstes jahr und ich habe
eine sache vergessen ziele grüßen lalit
aus indien mann du machst mir echt
freude mit deinen berichten und bildern
und eine beratung auch vielen dank
[Musik]